Good morning.
Uh,
as you can see,
the title of today's lecture is lifestyles of the rich and famous houses and
villas at Pompei.
We spoke last time about the public architecture of Pompei,
about the forum,
about the temples,
about the basilica,
about the Babs,
and also about,
uh,
shops and tombs as well.
Uh,
but today we're going to turn to the residential architecture of Pompei,
a residential architecture that is extremely important,
not only for what it tells us about palm pay,
but what it also tells us about domestic architecture in the first centuries BC
and the first century,
a d because there is no place where the houses are better preserved than at palm
pay.
So it tells us,
again,
not just about the city itself,
but also about residential architecture in Rome,
where we have very few examples and elsewhere in the Roman world.
I want to begin with the image that you see now on the screen,
which is a building.
Uh,
and we're talking about the one at the far at the left front left.
A building that is on one of palm pays main thoroughfares,
the via Dell Abbondanza,
the via del Abbondanza,
the street of abundance.
And the building in question is,
is relatively well preserved.
And what is significant about it,
about it for us right now is the fact that it is two storied as you can see
here.
What we'll see in the course of today's presentation is that most of the
buildings,
most of the houses in early Pompei are single story dwellings.
Uh,
but here we see one that is two storied and this two story dwelling actually
dates fairly late in the history of residential architecture and palm pay.
It dates sometime between the earthquake of 62 and the eruption of a [inaudible]
of 79.
So between 62 and 79 a d.
And we see that,
that it has two stories.
In this instance,
a story down below that may have been that it says has entrance ways might even
have been opened up as a shop.
And then a second story,
uh,
that is very interesting indeed and it has a,
what we call cannot realize,
Cen Acu,
l Aee,
conops July,
which are second story dining rooms that have open panoramic windows,
these windows as you can see through column.
So an interesting nod to Hellenization once again,
this idea of incorporating Greek elements into Roman architecture,
uh,
elements that again are under that are that come into Roman architecture through
the influence of earlier Greek architecture,
uh,
and views out through those columns.
So two important points,
one that these are have two stories and that the second that adding a second
story to a Roman building a is or a palm pay and building in this instance
doesn't occur until between the earthquake and the eruption of the service.
And secondarily,
this idea of the picture window and we've talked about the importance of the
Romans of Vista and Panorama and they're doing it here.
They're opening up that second floor so that you can sit in one of these dining
rooms and then have a very nice view out through the columns of the street and
the street life below.
Now this building,
uh,
on the,
via de la been Bundoran,
so lies at the end of the development of Pompey and domestic architecture.
And so what I'm going to do is take us back to the beginning and,
uh,
trace Rome,
palm and domestic architecture from the Sam night period up through the eruption
of the service with regard to the earliest houses at Pompei.
These were done during a,
again,
the saddened night period,
the fourth and third centuries BC.
Keep in mind that the sound and lights weren't Italk tribe that is indigenous to
Italy from way back when I had mentioned too that Pompei was founded already in
the eighth century BC and these atomic tribes,
uh,
built houses obviously in which they lived,
already in the fourth and third substantial houses in which they lived already
in the fourth and third centuries BC.
I want to begin our conversation about domestic architecture in Palm Bay and by
extension in Rome itself with the so called Domus Etol Alica.
Uh,
what was the Dome missy tallest of the dome.
He Aca was an ideal Roman House plan.
And we know quite a bit about it because of the writings of Vitruvian,
but Truvia is not to be confused with Vesuvius,
but Truvia is was an architectural theoretician who was writing in the age of
Augustus,
Augustus being Rome's first emperor and the Truvia has left a great deal of
writings about all kinds of architecture including domestic architecture and he
talks in detail about the Domus at Talico or the uh,
or the what he considered the ideal Roman house and he describes all of its
parts and through his writings we can explore together what the ideal Roman
house was and what you're going to find.
Very interesting I believe is the fact that the actual houses at Pompei can form
or the earliest houses conform very closely to this ideal plant.
Let's run through it together,
both in plan and in restored view.
Again,
I'm going to need to go over a lot of terminology here,
but I guarantee you I'm going to,
I'm going to repeat it enough today that it will be indelibly marked on your
minds and you won't even have to.
I don't think you'll even have to study this when the time comes because you're
going to know these parts of the house houses so well after we go through them
today.
Here you see the plan of the typical Domus.
He Taller Guy,
you can see it.
Number one is the entrance into the house.
The entrance to the house was called the foul ks,
Fau,
c,
e s the foul case or the throat of the house.
Sometimes the foul case was uh,
had it before it,
a vestibule called the vestibule them.
And all of these words are on the monument list for you of vestibular them,
which was a place right before the beginning of the fall case,
uh,
underneath the eaves of the house where you could actually stand,
get,
get in from the rain in case it was raining outside while you waited for the
door to be open.
But in these early,
these very early doe,
missy Tamika houses,
we don't tend to see the vestibule alum.
So think that a way for the moment,
just the foul Kaeser throat of the house.
Then on either side of the foul case,
there are two rooms which are called cells or cells cell,
ah,
uh,
in the singular and sell ice,
e.
L,
l.
I.
E in the plural.
These can be treated in a number of different ways.
They can either be closed off from the street,
uh,
and used as interior rooms for the house,
extra bedrooms or uh,
living and living spaces.
Or they can be as you see them in this ideal plan opened up to the street when
they are opened up to the street,
they take on the role of shops or to bear NY t a,
B,
e r n e shops or to bear NY.
And those shops could be either used by those who own the house,
uh,
to make additional money or they could be leased out to others,
to others for their shops.
Uh,
you see,
uh,
the foul Kay's leads into the most important room of a Roman house,
the so called atrium,
the famous atrium of the Roman house at t r.
I.
U.
M.
A.
The Atrium was the audience hall of the House.
And it's important to mention from the outset that Roman houses had a very
different role enrollment society than houses do for us today.
We tend to think of our houses today in large parts as retreats,
as places we could get away from it all,
get away from work and away from schoolwork and so on and escape.
Although we do enjoy,
obviously having friends and family visit us there,
we tend to think of it as a place of retreat.
This was not true in Roman times when the house was also a place to do some very
serious business.
The man of the house,
the head of the household,
the potter familias often greeted clients in the Atrium of the house and when he
was away on business or a at war,
his wife,
the Matera Familia Os would stand in for him and she would conduct business in
the atrium.
So considered a very public part of the house,
a place where you wanted it to look its best because you were going to be
greeting important visitors there to do business.
So the Atrium is located here.
You can see this rectangular pool in the center of the Atrium that is the
emplouee IOM and you have that on the monument lets the employee Veeham of the
house,
which is a pool in which they collected rainwater for daily use.
How did they collect that rain water?
Because there was a,
an opening in the ceiling,
also rectangular in shape that's called a calm plutonium and that and the calm
Plu beum uh,
had uh,
had surrounding it,
a slanted roof to encourage the water obviously to slide in through the comp
lithium and land in the [inaudible] down below,
uh,
around the Atrium and also around the employee are at four.
Here are the bedrooms of the house,
the cubic you alum in the singular and cubic que la in the plural,
the cubic ula or bedrooms of the house.
And you can see that each one of them opens up off the atrium.
They are very small in size,
smaller than any other rooms in the house.
And they were literally just a place to sleep.
They were very small,
mostly very dark.
Some of them had slipped windows.
I'll show you one of those later.
Many of them didn't have any windows.
They were literally just sleeping spaces.
Over here at five,
we see the wings or the ally,
a,
l a,
e the wings or the ally,
our law and the singular all I have the house,
the wings of the house.
We're a very important place in the point of view of family tradition and
religious practice and so on.
It was the place where the Romans kept the shrines of their ancestors.
They had wooden shrines,
they will usually made out of wood with um,
with doors.
And they kept inside those,
the busts and portraits of their ancestors.
And they would take those out.
They would open those shrines up and take those out on special occasions,
usually anniversaries,
marking,
uh,
the anniversary of the death of the deceased.
And they had an interesting practice in which the member of the family who most
closely resembled the deceased in size and general appearance would put on that
mask and participate in a kind of parade,
uh,
in honor of the debt.
So they kept those in those shrines in the wings or the ally of the house here
at six on axis.
And we know how much the Romans liked axiology as well as symmetry.
Uh,
we see the,
uh,
the room over here at six is on access with the Fao k's and the atrium.
This room is called the [inaudible] t a,
B,
l,
I,
N,
u m,
the to bleed them,
which started as the master bedroom of the house,
the most important bedroom,
much larger than the cubicles.
But over time it became a place where the family archives were kept.
And,
and beyond that,
and we'll see it happening in pretty early actually today.
Uh,
it becomes almost a kind of passageway between the Atrium and the area that lay
beyond here at seven.
We see,
uh,
the also a fairly large room,
the dining room or try Clinique them.
And you can see in this case and the ideal Roman house,
it opens off the Atrium so easy to get to from the atrium.
And then at the back,
number eight,
for one of these ideal Roman houses,
the Hortus,
h,
o,
r,
t,
u s or the garden of the house,
which was obviously open to the sky.
If you look at the restored view,
you can see how in the how these,
how these earliest houses really had a very enclosed feeling.
They were quite stark and geometrically ordered with very few openings are you
can see in this case,
this one opening,
uh,
as an entrance way into the fal case as well as into two shops as you can see
here.
And then of course the comp Lou beum a hole in the ceiling and then the hoarders
is open to the sky.
But other than that,
there are no windows whatsoever.
It's a very enclosed a structure and we're going to see that although that's the
case in the beginning,
that changes over time.
We'll see a very important and interesting evolution.
Now,
as I add,
another point that I want to make from the start is,
is just as in temple architecture and we've traced it,
the development of early Roman temple architecture where we saw the Romans
ultimately using combining and a trust can plan with a Greek elevation.
We're going to see something actually quite similar happening in the development
of a Palm Payan and Roman domestic architecture.
We're going to see that a trust skin earlier trust skin,
uh,
monuments had an impact.
And I show you uh,
a plan of an Etruscan tomb over here.
We've looked at this before and a trust can tomb over here just to show you that
the general arrangement of that tomb a with an entrance way here with two rooms
over here,
kind of like the to bear nigh that we looked at where the cells that we looked
at just before a big space over here,
not unlike the atrium,
the idea of axiology entering into it.
Then this large space,
then another space which mirrors that to bleed them or is likely to bleed them
of the Roman house.
And then other rooms on either side.
So this whole idea,
this progression of one space,
an axial progression of one space to another space,
to another space.
It's on the same axial focus.
Uh,
very important.
And I think those who were building these fairly early on the Sam nights and so
on,
we're clearly looking at a trust skin,
uh,
examples.
And it shows us very early on also that in the minds of the Romans,
it was a very close association between the houses of the living and the houses
of the dead.
Because if you look at the inside of this,
a trust in tomb,
and I mentioned it,
not holding you responsible for it,
but I mentioned it to you underneath the dome,
Missy Tamika on the monument list.
This is the tomb of the shields and seats in cheer Vettery of the sixth century
BC.
Uh,
and if you look at it,
you can see that inside the tomb it's all carved from the Rock,
from the Tufa rock.
You can see that it looks very much like what you'd expect to house to look like
with bands.
And notice the detail they've even provided is all done in stone.
The two fa stone,
but you see they've even provided stone pillows here.
Not very comfortable,
but it gives you the sense of of what a house would have been like.
And we know that houses that bed's in houses look very much like these over
here,
a throne with a nice footstool as you can see.
And then if you look very carefully,
also indicated in stone,
the rafters,
the beams,
uh,
done in stone and then the moldings around the door and around the shields,
which is the reason this is called the shields and the seats obviously as cause
if I seats in it as shields on the,
uh,
on the wall.
So I just wanted to make the point because it'll turn up a number of times in
the course of the semester,
the closest association in the mind to the Romans between cities of the houses
of the living and houses of the debt.
And also that important point that the early Sab night builders are looking at a
trust skin prototypes.
I want to show you now the way in which actual Pompei in houses can form very
closely.
The early ones,
at least of the fourth and third centuries BC conform very closely to this Domus
Vitalik a ideal plant.
I want to begin with the so called house of the surgeon in palm pay,
which dates to the third century BC and it's called the house of the surgeon
because of all the surgical instruments that were found in the house.
And I show you the array of them.
Now on the screen.
Uh,
this should be of considerable interest to especially,
and I know there are a number of you in here,
students whose major is biology.
And I want to mention also that you'd be,
you might be surprised to hear,
but maybe not yell,
has such amazing collections that the medical school has a collection of
surgical instruments that goes way back and it goes way back to ancient Rome.
You can actually see ancient Roman surgical instruments in that collection,
uh,
that we have here at Yale.
I'm not perhaps as many as this,
but an interesting selection.
Uh,
and uh,
those of you who are in that field might at 1.1 to take advantage of that and
get to see them firsthand.
So this house got its name from this cache of surgical instruments that were
found inside.
Uh,
that probably gives us some sense of the profession of at least one of the
people who was living here.
I show you the plan of the house of the surgeon and you'll see a version on your
monument list that actually has the rooms designated there,
which I don't have here.
So that will be helpful to you as you,
I wanted you to have that version so that you can,
when you're studying,
uh,
you have that before you and uh,
in any,
any exam,
by the way,
even if I show something slightly different in class,
I will show you only what is on your monument list in the exam.
So those are the ones that you should study and remember.
But you'll see the plan is exactly the same.
It just doesn't have the labels here.
So we can see that it conforms the house of the surgeon.
Third Century BC to the ideal at a Domus Etol Lik a plant you enter here,
you enter into the FAO case or throat of the house.
There are two cells,
one on either side.
It's very clear in plan that this cell is close to the outside and opens only
off the atrium,
so used by the family,
uh,
for their own purposes.
This one is open to the street,
clearly used as a shop either by this family or they've leased it out to
somebody else.
The atrium is on access.
With the foul case,
we can see that the atrium has a pool,
a rectangular pool or improve IOM and there would have been a calm blue beam up
above on either side,
the cubicles or bedrooms of the house opening off the atrium over here.
The wings or ally of the house for the ancestral shrines over here.
Again,
a a dining room,
a try Clinique them.
That opens off the Atrium up here we think probably a portico few columns,
one column or two,
but that might belong to a later renovation.
And I'll explain why in a moment.
And then in the back of somewhat irregularly shaped Hortus or garden.
But I think you can see from this example how closely these actual houses track.
Uh,
the Dome Missy Tall,
uh,
described by the Truvia is another example of one of these early Roman houses
that conforms to the Domus.
Etol Lik a tight is the so called house of Sallisaw and Tom pay that dates to
the third century BC.
This is another house that has the Domus he Talia as its core,
a Bot,
just like most of the houses in palm pay.
You'll remember,
remember how when the Romans took over palm pay an 80,
or made Pompei a Roman colony.
They tossed the soundbites out of their homes,
they took them over and of course,
once they took them over,
they renovated them.
So there's a quite a bit of renovation that takes place to some of these early
Sam night houses.
And this case,
the house of Salus,
uh,
seems to be an example of that.
But we still see the original core of the Domus.
He tall [inaudible] the entrance over here into the foul case of the house.
Uh,
one,
uh,
well I'll say something about that in a moment.
The Atrium on axis with that,
with the [inaudible] over here,
the all lie or wings here,
the [inaudible] of the house over here.
In this case,
you can see that the trickling IOM opens up off the,
toward the Hortus.
Instead,
this family wanted to provide views of the hardest rather than the atrium from
the dining hall.
Now what's particularly interesting and may belong to the renovation is the
shops that are opening up off the street because you can tell in plan exactly
how this shop was used.
Anyone volunteer to say based on the plan,
what kind of a shop was this?
A fast food style?
Yeah.
So fast food shop at Thermop oleum because we can see the counter and we can see
the recesses in plan.
So this family either had or let let it space out for one of these Napoleon for
one of these fast food stands,
uh,
in the front of their house.
So two examples.
The,
uh,
house of the surgeon and the House of salad that conform closely,
third century BC to the original Vitalik a plan in the second century BC.
We see something happen in house designed quite extraordinary and that is linked
to the same kind of development we saw in temple architecture.
And that is a yes,
they've been looking at the Etruscan type of plan.
They'd been conforming to that to a certain extent.
All of a sudden in the second century,
they get the bug,
uh,
to make their houses look more Greek and they begin to incorporate elements of
that they take from earlier Greek architecture.
And the result is quite extraordinary.
I'm showing you here an example of an ideal,
a plan of what we call the Hellenized Domus,
the Domus that has been hellenized that has been given Greek l.
It has been enhanced with Greek elements and we let's want run through the plan
again,
a of the so called Hellenized Domus type.
Uh,
you can see that,
uh,
the core is the same as the Dome Missy Tamika,
you enter over here.
Here we can see in plan the incorporation of the vestibular,
this vestibule that come,
that that,
that,
uh,
is located right in front of or at the beginning of the foul case.
Uh,
the purpose of which you can see it right here.
The purpose of what you've just,
you've kind of entered into the house.
The,
the roof of the House protects you in case the weather is not good,
but you still have to stand in that vestibule until you're allowed into the foul
k's and the rest of the house.
So we see here the vestibular,
the foul case,
the two cells cell I one on either side.
In this case they are not opened up as shops.
The atrium here with its emplouee IOM to catch rain water at four we have the
usual a Qubica Ula or bedrooms at five we have the usual ally or wings and then
six that to bleed them on axis with seven the try Klinean opening off the
atrium.
So once again,
the core of the original Domus,
he tall like a very much intact in the hellenized domus but look what's happened
up here.
What's happened up here is it number eight,
under the influence of Greek architecture under the influence of what's
happening in temple architecture,
they incorporate columns in to the interior of the house.
Uh,
and they place their garden.
Here it's a garden court,
uh,
with columns,
which technically is called a Paris style,
And it is comparable to what we see in temple architecture.
When we saw the art,
the,
uh,
architects,
um,
giving some of the temples,
the peripheral colonnade,
you remember the colonnade that goes all the way around and it's free standing
under the influence of Greek architecture.
It's the same sort of thing here,
except it's on the inside of the building.
So this peristyle court come garden,
uh,
located right here.
And then on either side,
additional bedrooms or cubicles or these were probably very desirable to have a
bedroom that opened,
had a nice view out over your garden.
And then back here to additional,
uh,
try Clinique,
two additional dining rooms,
uh,
to take advantage of the beautiful views,
that one could get if one could see it.
Probably not terribly much that,
these narrow doorways,
but at least opening up on to the peristyle court.
We see Neil one second.
Just we see up here the restored view showing the same,
the entranceway.
And look here,
you can even see columns added,
uh,
in the front to announce from the very start that this is a house,
that is,
that is owned by a very cultured individual who knows his Greek,
uh,
and knows his Greek culture,
and knows to incorporate these wreak elements into his house.
Then we see the comp Lumion,
we see the peristyle from above.
You can see open to the sky with columns,
but still very stark,
very plain on the outside,
no windows to speak of.
Very much an enclosed space.
Neil,
some of these houses did have kitchens and I'll show you an example in a moment
and probably more of them did them.
We then we're sure of,
uh,
it's just a question of what remains in terms of being able to determine that.
But we certainly have examples of that.
So they did seem to have kitchens.
So now I want to show you some examples of houses that conform to the hellenized
domus type.
Uh,
this being the first one.
It's one of the most famous houses in palm pay.
And if you're making,
if you're going there any time soon and are making a list of must sees,
this is one of those Macies in palm paid the house of the Betty e the vetting we
think it belongs or that we're not absolutely sure to the various brothers,
to the various brothers in palm pay.
And a date is the monument.
A list indicates to the second century BC and later looking at this plan,
you can see the way in which it conforms to the hellenized Domus type.
Once again,
it has the core,
it has the dome,
he tall like a core,
the entrance way over here with the FAO case,
the cells on either side,
the in this case used as a rooms internal to the house.
They do not open off the street as shops.
The atrium here with the [inaudible],
a smaller number of cubic ula on either side.
Uh,
all I over here,
look what has happened to the [inaudible] it to bleed them is gone.
Essentially.
All it consists of is a couple of Bay Pilasters,
uh,
that are located right here.
And I'll show them to you in a moment cause it's WellPreserved pilasters here.
So it to bleed them has essentially disappeared.
It's become a kind of passage way,
uh,
from the core of the house into the garden.
And it is a peristyle garden surrounded by columns as you can see and you can
see how important that peristyle garden has become.
This family has decided to decrease.
Uh,
there are other space in order to have this stupendously large garden here and
they have also put a very large dining hall,
try cleaning up here.
That opens off the Paris style and it has a much bigger opening,
uh,
so that they could clearly dine and get views of this,
of this garden.
Uh,
this peristyle garden of which they were obviously incredibly proud.
so some,
some major changes.
They are now this particular house.
Oh,
I did want to say though,
despite those changes,
the house is still very enclosed and very,
very plain and stark from the outside.
This is a restored view of what we believe the outside looked like,
sort of geometrically ordered cubic.
As you can see just one entrance way,
possibly a few small windows,
possibly not a,
and then you can see the comp Lou BM and the Paris style court.
But otherwise very much in closed like the earlier Domus Vitalik and not much
change with regard to how the exterior of the building is treated.
This again is one of the reasons everyone flocks to this house is it's very well
preserved.
There's been some restoration work of course,
uh,
but it really,
this is one of those must seize because it really gives you as good a sense as
anything of what these houses looked like in antiquity.
We have obviously entered into,
we've come through the foul case.
Uh,
we are standing in the atrium,
we can see the pool or [inaudible] here we can see the comp.
Lou Vient very well preserved up above.
I think it's probably the best preserve calm blue beam that we have or close to
it.
And you can see that there were a little anti fixes added in terracotta and
stuff as decoration up at the top.
As we're standing here,
we look back through what was once the to bleed them and now is basically a
point of transition,
a passageway from the Atrium to the most important part of the house from the
point of view of these patrons,
the garden.
Uh,
so you're looking through,
you see these great peers,
uh,
on either side that are all that's left of the to blend them.
You look through that and you see the garden.
The garden has its columns surrounding it.
The walls are painted of that,
of that garden.
Uh,
all a very lively and wonderful,
uh,
interior.
And what also comes v becomes very clear and looking at this particular view is
something that we've already discussed.
And that is the importance in the minds of the Romans of Vista or Panorama of
great views that you can see from one part of a building to another.
Remember the sanctuary of Jupiter anchor at Terra Cheena and all of those
wonderful lateral and an axial entrances and exits where there were all kinds of
interest in light effects.
We see the same sort of thing here.
The idea is to pass from a particularly well lighted area outside into a darker
area.
The foul case,
then a little bit more light added to the system through the comp Lube,
IOM,
and then a whole host of light that you can see in the distance,
the open because of the open peristyle.
So dark,
light,
dark light,
I,
there's progression of space is progression of life.
Uh,
through this structure.
I have a very typical Roman thing to do.
Uh,
the other,
other thing of course is this emphasis on axiology the of this movement through
a structure in a very axial way.
Uh,
the,
uh,
garden here as it looks today,
it would have been of course even more beautiful in antiquity when it would have
been in better shape.
But nonetheless,
this gives you,
it's been overgrown now and so on.
But it gives you some sense of what it would've looked like with the greenery in
the garden surrounded by the columns with,
uh,
you know,
with,
with garden furniture,
a little fountains,
a little marble fountains and the like,
uh,
and with the walls,
paintings are not in very good shape today,
but imagine them more vibrant.
And I'm going to show you examples of that on Thursday and next week of some of
the paintings that are in better condition,
how vibrant this would have been with those paintings.
Look also at the columns because you can see,
we'll see that some of these columns are made out of stone.
Some of them are made out of those,
um,
those tiles,
those look like bricks that I've shown you before.
But in all cases they were stuccoed over white.
Why were they stuccoed over white to make them look like Greek marble?
So once again,
this Hellenization of Roman domestic architecture,
this attempt to make these things look as Greek as possible.
Neil,
you asked about the kitchen.
Well,
this is our best preserve kitchen,
uh,
from Palm Pompei.
It's really quite amazing.
There's a stove and the pots and pans that were clearly a still sitting on the,
um,
sitting on,
on the stove at the time.
This particular family had to flee from the,
um,
from the thumb Vesuvius and I neglected to show you,
but you can look at the monument list for this plan where the,
where the rooms are marked.
Uh,
you will see the kitchen marked on that plan and you will also see what's called
the women's quarters marked on that plan,
which was probably where,
uh,
some of the slaves who were owned by this particular family,
the Betty,
his brothers,
uh,
lived in that,
in that area.
Another example of a house that conforms upon pay in house that conforms to the
Hellenized Domus type is the one that you now see on the screen.
It's a plan of the House of the silver wedding in palm pay.
A,
we believe it was remodeled in the first century BC,
although it's controversial,
it might have been remodeled a bit later in the first century.
A D uh,
it,
um,
it's an interesting structure had got its name,
the House of the silver wedding because it,
there was a lot of fanfare in the late 19th century.
I think it was precisely 1893 when the king and Queen of Italy came to visit
this particular houses and it became their favorite and uh,
so the silver wedding is actually a reference to them and to their marriage and
so on and so forth.
It's a wonderful house and I think you can see how it conforms.
Again,
it has a core that is very much,
they don't miss he tall like a core,
but it is another example of one of these houses that has been remodeled.
A because of the page,
the owner's interest in Helen Ising that house.
We enter here through the foul case,
uh,
there their cells on either side opening off the Fao case.
That's an unusual arrangement.
Then over here,
the uh,
atrium with the [inaudible],
the cubicles lie on either side,
the cell,
the uh,
ally or wings of the house,
a dining room over here,
uh,
to peristyle courts,
one in the back,
a smaller one,
and then a huge peristyle court over here on the left hand side.
So for this family,
one was not enough.
They wanted double the garden space.
Uh,
and they've,
they've allotted a lot of space in this house to those gardens.
Then most interesting of all,
I think about this house and the reason I chose it to show to you,
uh,
is that we are starting to see the Hellenization of the Atrium as well because
look what's happened to the atrium.
They have placed four columns around the improved IOM in the atrium.
So it wasn't enough to have these two large Paris styles.
They wanted columns everywhere and they place these four around the employee
Veeham a an atrium that has four columns in it is technically called,
and I put it on the monument list for you,
a tech risk style atrium.
This is a Texas style atrium.
Even that wasn't enough.
Look at that room in the upper left.
That room in the upper left is a banqueting hall,
uh,
and additional dining space,
but especial dining space.
Then you can see opens up very nicely off the smaller peristyle at the house.
The opening is fairly wide,
so it probably would have had some wonderful views of the peristyle garden.
And look,
there are four columns in there as well.
Uh,
and this particular banqueting hall,
its technical name,
it's got a kind of a funny name that I don't think you'll forget,
uh,
called an [inaudible],
o e c u s,
and is even more amusing in the plural because the plural is OEC.
I eeky eeky.
So,
uh,
this is an Ecos,
among Eeky,
uh,
an eco is up there and you can see that it's an ecosystem that has four columns
in it.
So we call it a tech style.
[inaudible] hi.
So now that we've had an opportunity to look at the plan of the House of the
silver wedding,
I want to give you a sense of what the building looks like today.
It's not as well preserved as the house of the Betty,
uh,
but we can get a very good sense of what it was like an antiquity and the
[inaudible],
uh,
which in some respects is the most important room in the house from our
standpoint is very well preserved.
We're looking here at a view,
we're standing again in the beginning of the atrium looking through the atrium.
We see the emplouee beum of the house,
a lot of Mawson's of over,
you know,
it's overgrown,
uh,
today.
Uh,
but nonetheless you can see it there as well as the comp bluebeam above what's
most important to us.
As you can see that this is indeed a tetris style atrium with four columns that
are surrounding the implant eum uh,
those columns and those columns supporting the ceiling.
And of course the comp bluebeam above also interesting is the way in which the
columns are treated.
You can see that they have been floated and then stuccoed over.
Do you remember the temple at Corey that we looked at where we talked about the
fact that uh,
the temple of Hercules at Cory,
we talked about the fact that the columns were fluted part of the way and then
down below those flutes were covered over with stucco and the Stucco was
painted.
We see the same thing here and if you look very,
very closely,
you can even see the remains of the red paint,
the red paint that decorated the lower part of these columns.
So some in correspondence as they are in terms of building practice.
You can also see here as we saw in the house of the Vte,
this wonderful vista from the Atrium of the house through what remains of the to
bleed them into the garden of the house,
uh,
at the peristyle garden of the house,
which from the patrons point of view was one of the most important or if not the
most important part of the house.
This is the [inaudible] of the house,
uh,
of the silver wedding.
And you can see it as extremely well preserved.
And you can also see how very interesting it is and all kinds of ways.
It is a tech restyle Egus.
Again,
a banqueting hall tetras style [inaudible],
uh,
with four columns.
Uh,
those columns are stuck out and painted over.
The paint is very well preserved.
It's a reddish,
purplish color,
probably meant to conjure up porphyry Por p,
h y r y a porphyry which comes only from Egypt.
It's only quarried and each of very expensive,
uh,
to bring it that great distance all the way to palm pay.
Uh,
and of course this isn't poor free,
it's just a painted column.
But the whole idea of this from the point of the point of the pain,
the patrons point of view was to look like he,
uh,
he and she were very well healed,
that they could afford,
uh,
to bring,
that they're trying to make the illusion that they could afford to bring,
uh,
this expensive stone from very far away to use in their house here.
Uh,
look also at the fact that the,
uh,
there's a barrel vault.
This is actually a wooden involved rather than a concrete vault here in this
room,
but very nicely done.
And the walls are extensively painted.
Uh,
they are weathered today.
but they give you a very good sense of the original of what would have been the
original appearance of this room.
And as I mentioned,
we'll talk in detail about Roman wall painting,
especially because as you can see,
it does depict architecture.
We'll begin that conversation on Thursday and continue into next week.
I want to turn now to what is surely,
uh,
the most important surviving house at the city of palm pay.
And this is the famous house of the phone.
If you have,
if you're in Palm Bay and you only have time to see two houses,
you go to the house of the Betty and the house of the Fawn,
uh,
the house of the phone.
As you can see from your monument list dates to the second century BC for the
most part.
Uh,
and uh,
we see a view of part of Pompei over here with a series of houses marked in
yellow.
And the reason that I show this to you is because the house or the phone is
particularly large.
You can see from this plan that it takes up,
in fact the entire block of an entire block of the city of palm pay.
And it is much larger than some of the others.
For example,
look at the house of the vets.
He over here,
it's,
it's almost,
it's twice if not larger than that twice the size of the house of the Betty,
if not even more than that.
So,
uh,
it's a very large house.
Clearly no expense was spared either an accumulating the property,
uh,
and also in enhancing the decor of the house.
If we look at a plan of the house of the phone,
we will see without question that it corresponds and it follows the hellenized
don't miss type.
We enter over here.
Uh,
we see it has a vestibule alum and vestibular them at Fau case to sell lie one
on either side and atrium with an improved IOM.
The cubicles are here on either side,
the wings or the ally,
it does have a to bleed them.
You see it over here and then it has to,
uh,
to Paris style courts,
with columns in circling them,
a smaller one,
and then a very large one in the back note.
Also,
while this is on the screen,
that there is a very interesting room that is located over here.
Uh,
it's a rectangular room.
It has,
uh,
a couple of columns on bases and pilasters one on either side.
It opens right off the peristyle court and on the floor of that space,
which we call the Alexander Exedra,
e e d r a after Alexander the great,
because on the floor of that was the most famous mosaic that we have surviving
from antiquity.
That represents Alexander the Great,
and I'll show you that momentarily.
First,
let me show you what the house looks like from the outside.
It's WellPreserved doesn't have its ceiling the way the house of the Betty he
does,
but otherwise it's pretty well preserved.
We're looking down the street on which it finds itself.
You see the polygonal masonry blocks,
you see the,
the,
um,
uh,
the,
you see the sidewalks here as well and how modern they look.
You see the stepping stones and overhear the facade of the house of the font.
You can see the entrance way and you can see that the entrance way has on either
side,
a Pilaster,
a pilaster with a Corinthian capital above.
And that's very important because it's announcing to us as did that ideal Helen
has don't miss that I showed you before.
It's announcing to us that this is a patron.
This is an owner of this particular house who guys leanings toward things,
Greek,
uh,
and wants us to know that even before we have entered into the house.
If you go into the house,
uh,
and stand in the vestibule,
you will see that there is still quite a bit of decoration preserved.
Uh,
the walls are painted with blocks.
What would it look like?
Blocks of stone and illusion.
Uh,
is is an example of first style wall painting.
We're going to talk about that on Thursday.
And then up here,
a shrine is still preserved.
A shrine that probably held statues are statuettes of some of the household gods
and revered God's,
uh,
for this family.
This is an excellent view because it shows us again how if he entering this
house,
you would stand in the vestibule,
you'd go from there into the Fao Ks,
uh,
then into the atrium,
then into the peristyle that lay beyond the first smaller one,
and then the larger one after that.
But it shows us again,
the point that I've made so many times already just in this first part of the
semester.
And that is this Roman interest in Vista or Panorama.
They've set up a view from the moment in which you enter the house,
a view of a sequence of experiences from light to dark,
to light to dark,
uh,
but also at a sequence of visual experiences that make,
entering this house and walking through this house and extraordinary experience.
One that they have helped enhance.
And you can also see again,
the capitols here.
Here's a view of the Atrium as it looks today,
we are standing in front of the [inaudible] in that employ VM is a statuette and
bronze of the dancing fon from which this house gets its name.
The one that you see there now is a copy and the original is in the
archeological museum in Naples.
This view also shows you the way in which you had the series of visual
experiences from the foul case to the Atrium and ultimately toward the peristyle
with its wonderful forest of columns done Allah Grech in the Greek style.
Here's another interesting view where it's still in the atrium.
You can see the dancing fon right here.
We're looking at the sidewall.
If we're facing the fon,
this is the wall to the left.
This is very helpful because it shows us exactly what it would,
what the,
the cubicles that opened off the atrium would have looked like.
You can see that they were very dark.
Some of them had these tiny slit windows or perhaps slightly larger slit
windows,
but for the most part they were very dark.
Again meant only as a place to sleep at night and to be used for no other
purpose than that.
You can also see from this,
this a view that this is a rubble wall that has been stuccoed over,
uh,
and that reliefs painted different colors have been placed on that wall.
This is an example of so called first style Roman wall painting.
And we'll go into the,
into what that defined,
what that was and discuss it in more detail on Thursday.
This is a wonderful restored view of what the house of the form would have
looked like when all of its first style Roman wall painting was intact,
uh,
showing,
what it would've looked like to stand in the atrium and look back through what
survived the,
to bleed them with these very large pilasters,
again,
announcing the Greek leanings of this particular patron,
and then the view,
uh,
to toward the peristyle where you would also see the columns,
that looked like they were very much in the Greek style.
So here's clearly a person who not only is building his home to correspond to
the latest and domestic architecture,
namely the Helen Hayes,
don't miss type,
but who just wants to make that point over and over and over again that he's
cultivated,
that he knows things Greek,
uh,
and that he has the funds to be able to incorporate those into his house.
And indeed,
first style wall painting is we'll find out when we discuss it is also a style
then is based on Greek prototypes.
So another example of the Greek elements in this building.
What room do you think this is?
I can't,
oh,
I didn't show you this on the plan.
I neglected to,
but you can look at your monument list.
You'll see that when you look at the plan,
you'll see that this house had more than one atrium.
It had two atria and this is one of them.
It's a tech restyle a dream.
Cause you can see there are four columns,
one around each of the,
uh,
of the um,
one,
one around each corner of the employee.
Theum.
So a house with two Paris dolls,
a house with two atriums,
uh,
and even one of the atriums has four columns as you can see here.
And this one is also very useful for the fact,
one of you asked me a question when we were looking at the Basilica Pompei about
why,
uh,
you know,
why the columns look the way they did.
I think it was you and you can send,
I mentioned that they were pieced and here you can see that very well.
These drums placed one on top of another so that you can see over time how easy
it would be for some of those to fall off or become dismantled.
And for us to be left with the sort of thing that we're left with when we look
at what remains in the basilica of Pompei.
Here's a view obviously of one of the Paris styles here.
You also see something interesting in terms of building technique.
The columns in palm pay tend to be either of local stone,
a local Tufa,
or made up these,
um,
brick,
these tiles that look like bricks.
But then in either case,
stuccoed over white,
polluted to make them look once again,
like they aren't marble columns,
the illusion that they are marble columns even though they are not,
uh,
to underscore their Greekness.
Uh,
this is a view of the,
um,
that Exedra,
that Alexander Exedra that I mentioned to you before that opens off the first
Paris style,
uh,
with two columns on bases here.
Note the red at the bottom,
white at the top,
two pilasters painted red as you can see.
And you can see the tourists there.
Gazing down there,
gazing down at a copy.
And this copy by the way of a,
for a very long time in for as long as I remember going there,
except for this last time I was there,
there was nothing there.
And I think most people had no realization that this amazing mosaic originally
was on the floor.
Uh,
but they have put a copy of the mosaic is now in the Naples archeological museum
long ago.
Moved there,
but they finally put a copy down on the floor.
Uh,
so that of the mosaic that was there so that people who visit the house of the
phone realize,
oh,
this is where the Alexander Mosaic was located,
which is particularly important because this is a view of the,
of the mosaic,
this extraordinary mural mosaic of Alexander the great that's now in the Naples
archeological museum.
And of course you can see that they display it there as if it were a panel
picture hanging on the wall.
But that is not how it was displayed are meant to be displayed in the house of
the phone.
It was a floor pavement in the house of the form.
But look how nicely,
at least in the museum they have recreated the ambiance by putting the columns
and the pilasters and they tried to recreate the sense of the ECC Dra just as it
is in the house.
It's just that they put the,
the mosaic and the wrong place.
It should be on the floor.
Uh,
nonetheless you can see it's an extraordinary work of art.
I'm not going to go into it in great detail,
but I did want to expose you to it because it is so important and so
magnificent.
And I also want to make absolutely sure that you don't miss when you go to the
Naples,
to the Palm Bay area.
You do not miss going to the archeological museum in Naples.
It's an amazing museum,
one of the greatest of all the museums in Italy.
And it has,
of course,
almost all the great stuff that comes from palm pay is at that museum today.
So it's another one of those asterisks must sees a,
you look at it here,
it represents the battle between Alexander and the Persian King Darius,
d a r I,
U s at the famous battle of Isis I s s u s.
A.
And uh,
at that battle,
Alexander was victorious.
Uh,
and uh,
you see it here.
And one of the reasons that it's so important for our understanding of the house
of the Fawn is that we believe that this mosaic was a copy of an earlier last
Greek painting,
a Greek painting of this same scene of Alexander and Darius done in around 300
BC by a Greek painter that was copied for this house in mosaic,
uh,
sometime in the second century BC.
So it's another example of this patron of this owner of the house who is so
besotted with Greek art that he wants to have as much of it around him as he
possibly can.
And he clearly has the assets that enable him to,
uh,
commission,
a mosaic assist to make this amazing painting.
Now,
there are a lot of people who talk about this,
this,
this mosaic,
excuse me.
A lot of people that talk about this mosaic and they say,
well,
you know,
it's such a pale reflection of what the painting would have been.
And you know,
it's a typical derivative Roman art.
Did that look at Greek art and derive from it?
They couldn't come up with anything on their own,
but I would maintain that's absolutely untrue.
But I would also maintain that to do this kind of work in mosaic rather than
paint is much more difficult.
I mean,
this is a true tour de force to be able to create this kind of active battle
scene with collapsing horses and uh,
with,
um,
with spears in the sky for shortened,
done for shortened weapons down here.
This is an amazing thing to do in Mosaiq when you think of all of these
individual tests or these small stores,
small stones,
multicolored stones that had to be brought together,
placed in mortar,
uh,
to create this amazing tableau.
To me it seems like it is much,
much greater feat to have to achieve that and to achieve it so well in mosaic.
Then in paint,
just quickly a couple of details.
Here's the one of Alexander himself on his horse.
It's an incredible characterization of the Great Hellenistic,
uh,
general and King and you see him on his favorite horse boot capitalists here.
And I think it's a wonderful characterization by this particular very talented
mosaicism.
And his workshop,
uh,
to capture the relationship of man and horse.
I mean,
if you look at not only the eyes but also at the hair,
the hair of Alexander tussled flowing in the wind,
the Mane of the Horse so closely aligned with one another,
the artists has really very effectively captured that.
Again,
even just using these very small pieces of stone,
which you can see very well here.
Look at the way the shadows that are cast,
you know,
even by that stone,
it's,
it's incredible.
Here's the other detail that I'm going to show you of Darius on in his chariot.
Uh,
he,
his driver,
as you can see,
he's looking toward Alexandra.
He's mesmerized by the great Hellenistic king,
but he's at the same time afraid.
Uh,
and he's beating a retreat because you can see that his driver has turned the
chariot around.
He's whipping the horse and he's heading in the other direction away from
Alexander as is this figure.
Here we see his horse from the rear,
a real tour de force of depicting a horse.
Uh,
but he too is looking at Alexander quite afraid.
And his horse is also turning to go off into the distance.
So capturing this very dramatic moment and to me the most wonderful,
uh,
detail is this one that you see down here,
which is a view of one of the fallen Persians.
The Shield is falling over on him,
but the shield is,
is,
is polished to such a shine that he can see the reflection of his own face.
I have a detail to show you of this.
He can see the reflection.
You see it here of his own face in that shield.
And this view is particularly good.
I took this one very close up so that you could see,
uh,
the individual stones.
You don't even it from a distance,
they blend,
but when you go up close you can really see,
oh yeah,
that's,
that's a mosaic and it's,
it's really an extraordinary work of art.
Very quick question because
they're very small,
they're very small.
And the reason for that is in large parts of that,
they will blend ultimately and from a distance it will have the feel of a
painting.
Certainly when it's on the wall,
probably less so when you stood and looked at it in its original location
because you'd be looking down on it and you'd be closer to it than here.
But it's an amazing work.
And again,
remember that although the original painting done by the Greek painter was
probably did hang on a wall,
uh,
this one was meant as a floor mosaic in this house,
but again,
a testament to the Greek leanings of this particular patron.
Now I also wanted to show you that's not the only mosaic in palm pay.
It's the greatest by far without question.
And I think everyone who studies this stuff would agree with me that it's the,
the finest surviving mosaic and the history of ancient Greek and Roman art.
Uh,
but there are plenty of other modes mosaics preserved,
including at palm pay.
And I want to show you just one.
It's mentioned underneath the Alexander Mosaic on your monument list because
it's so beloved,
it's even more beloved by most tourists to the site.
Then the Alexander Mosaic,
which after all you can't see on the site and you have to see it in Naples,
at least the original.
But uh,
this is the so called Callway condom mosaic,
and it belongs to the House of the tragic poet,
a house that was put up between 62 and 79 a d and you see what's meant to be a
very ferocious dog with his teeth bared.
This one has done much more simply and only three colors,
mainly black and white test Ari or small stones,
It's what these small stones are called,
the test Iri,
black and white,
basically black on white.
Uh,
but you can see that there's one touch of red,
the color of the dog,
and the dog is chained.
As you can see,
just like that poor,
a plaster cast of the dog that we saw last time.
He's chained,
but he's meant to look very ferocious.
He's baring his teeth and the whole point call icon and beware of dog is for you
to be a war.
And of the fact that if you dare step any further than that,
vestibule them and try to get into this house or try to steal anything or
whatever,
this dog will attack.
So it's the same kind of,
it's like a security alarm system actually for antiquity.
And you can,
I bet you can tell me where in the house this a mosaic was located.
Neil in the,
in the vestibule and where the foul case of the house.
Yeah,
probably the vestibule.
I'm actually indeed the vestibule of the house.
So that even before you got into,
as far as the fal case,
you were warned that you'd better be aware of the dog and this thing.
I mean you will see this.
Any of you been to palm pay?
No.
This and can attest that on,
right?
Every single souvenir stand anywhere within any,
any numbers of yards of Pompei is selling the call way cotton.
I'm on everything you can possibly imagine the mugs,
the t shirts,
the hot plates,
the whatever,
the tote bags,
you can get the call icon,
condom and every shape,
size and possibility.
And I have one of those myself.
Only one,
one hot plate.
But that's it.
I dive.
I did it.
I did it like everybody else at one point years ago.
Uh,
I want to show you briefly a couple of other houses just to make,
uh,
some,
a few small points while important points,
uh,
an important point or two about each of them.
The first one is the house of [inaudible] in palm pay,
which dates to the second century BC and later,
uh,
you see it in plan here,
the house of the [inaudible] like everything else we've seen in the latter part
of this lecture is a Hellenized Domus.
Uh,
you can tell that because of the Paris style here,
in other respects,
it's very similar to everything we've seen.
The usual foul k's,
atrium,
cubic ulum to bleed them system,
the,
uh,
large Paris style up here and some dining spaces opening off that Paris style.
What makes this particular house interesting.
And the reason that I show it to you is it's a good illustration of what happens
when over time you remodel and also over time when other a property becomes
available nearby.
And we can tell from this plan that what happened here is that the core of the
house was added to as property on either side,
additional property became available and this owner purchased that property and
added it,
uh,
and the plan becomes much more irregular obviously because of that.
An addition over here,
in addition over here,
you know,
some of that sense of axiology and symmetry is lost when you start to add to
either side horizontally.
Uh,
but there are lots of houses like this and it's one of the things one needs to
keep in mind as one,
as one visits the city and as one looks at each of these incredible structures.
Just very quickly with regard to the house,
just as you have a sense of what it looks like today,
it's named the house of Manana because of this painting of the poet,
uh,
who sits on a chair over there on one of the walls of the house.
Uh,
the part of the peristyle is actually quite well preserved as is the atrium
we're standing in the atrium,
as you can obviously see with the employee beum.
Looking back toward the garden.
This is interesting because you can see again the the uh,
cubicles opening off either side but also because of the incorporation justice
in the house of the font of columns elsewhere.
Then just in the Paris style,
these in that transition place between the Atrium and the um,
the garden,
the so called to bleed them space.
These very large columns stuccoed over fluted and you can see in this case,
not painted red at the bottom,
but a kind of bright yellow to match the colors of the wall.
So again,
this incorporation of Greek elements into houses like this one.
This is also a good view.
It's a very well preserved house and we're back in the atrium again,
you can see the way in which the cubicles to the small cubicles are open off
that you can see some of the paintings and you,
here's the entrance way through the foul case.
And you can see in this particular case a small shrine,
this located in the corner of the purpose of that for the household to display
the household gods.
This is another interesting house that I just wanted treat fleetingly.
It's the so called house of Panza in palm pay and it dates to the second century
BC.
Uh,
and it's a very large houses.
You can see like all the other hellenized a misses because we see that it has a
peristyle,
uh,
with columns here.
Uh,
it like all the others,
it has everything that we've seen,
the vestibular and the foul case,
the atrium,
the cubicles are the wings or all lie the to bleed them a dining room.
Uh,
and uh,
a bevy of shops down here in fact,
more shops than we have seen a be the case in most of the houses.
We've looked at at least five if not six shops down here,
which gives us something of a clue to something that might be going on in this
house.
If we go back to the peristyle and we take a look at that,
we see that there's a pool in,
in between the columns and you might Spec,
and I know how nice,
you know,
a nice,
pleasant pool.
You could sit around and you could dip your hands or your feet into that pool
was nice,
pleasurable spot to enjoy.
Well actually it wasn't that at all.
We think now that it was probably a pool that held fish and fish,
not fish,
just attract the fish that one could admire but actually fish that one that were
sold in one of the shops in front.
One of the reasons we believe that is a scholar by the name of Wilhelmina,
your Shamsky whose specialty is gardens of Pompei has spent her whole scholarly
career and it was well worth it cause she's come up with some extraordinary
things on studying the root marks,
uh,
of the gardens in palm pay.
And she's been able to demonstrate through studying those and working with
experts on that sort of thing.
Just what was grown in these gardens.
And you find that some of them were pleasure gardens with beautiful flowers and
some of them were produced gardens and this one was a produce garden so that
there would have been vegetables and fruits and so on that were,
that were gardened here.
Uh,
and then you,
and then they were sold in the shops that were located at the front.
So here we see a wonderful example of the way in which,
uh,
these houses could even be used by some owners as a means of income for them and
for their families.
And that was surely the case with the house of Panza.
It also has a very WellPreserved peristyle.
We can see the column c are around that pool that was used to hold the fish that
were sold in one of the shops are the columns are extremely WellPreserved,
including some of the capital's ionic capitals,
as you can see here.
And the fluting.
And then the plane,
you know,
this stuccoed over at the bottom with the paint.
We can see in this case remains of the red paint that would have decorated the
bottom part of those columns.
Another very interesting house.
Uh,
well,
you know,
interesting house in one that's important for us because it marks a,
a,
a later development in a Roman house architecture in palm pay is the house of
Marcus Lorraine.
This timber,
Tina's,
remember bar was the ancient word for Tivoli.
And so it's likely that tee routine is in fact came from Tivoli move to Palm
Pompei and built this large house,
uh,
sometime between the earthquake and the eruption of Vesuvius.
So 62 to 79,
a d like the house of the phone.
It took up an entire city block.
Uh,
and,
but you can see that the owner has made a different decision then the owner of
the house of the Fawn,
because the house itself takes up very little space and most of this space is
taken up by the garden.
We're less sure here whether this was a pleasurable garden there,
there are some indications that it might have been or whether it too was used as
a produce garden.
We don't have all those shops on the front,
so that seems less likely here.
But you can see it's another example of the way in which these houses are
becoming not only more personalized,
but also with much more emphasis on the garden and on the dining rooms that are
surrounding that garden.
We see one of those dining rooms here.
What's particularly interesting about this house and one that helps us round the
circle to where I began at the beginning of the lecture when I talked about the
fact that it was between 62 and 79 that the,
that the pump patients began to build second stories on their houses.
They,
they,
they began to expand vertically and we saw the Canaliculi of the via Dell
abundance of building.
We see the same thing happening here,
that a second story has been added around the living quarters.
Now here it was obviously really needed because they were giving much base to
the living quarters.
So they had to build up vertically for those.
And if you look very carefully at the restored view,
you will see that the windows of that second story open off,
uh,
and look out over onto the calm plutonium of the,
um,
of the atrium.
You see that they're the conclusion of the atrium.
And then around it you can see the second story,
uh,
with the windows looking out over the complete VM of the house.
Then the rest,
needless to say,
garden,
it's actually pretty well preserved.
It's fun to wander around.
You see these wonderful trellises and all kinds of of art,
interesting architectural forms that form that,
that are part of this incredible garden in the house of timber.
Tina's.
And you even see there this magnificent grotto,
which leads me to believe that we're beginning to see something interesting
here,
which is the incorporation of the sorts of things that you would tend to see in
villas,
not right in the center of a city,
uh,
but villas that were located either outside the city or a long or along the
coast or along the coast.
Uh,
and um,
and the reason I say that here is because we can see this grotto like effect,
uh,
where we have what looks like a pebbled effect on the back wall,
painted a two columns,
Corinthian columns with um,
uh,
a pediment above.
And then these two wonderful mythological paintings.
One you probably recognize as the myth of Narcissus.
You can see his reflection in the water.
He's of miring himself and his reflection down below.
And then Pyramus and Thisbe over here.
What's important to us is not which myths but just that Greek myths are
incorporated into the scheme here.
So this a pretension toward things Greek but most important,
this sort of this grotto like element that you would tend to find in a villa
along the Amalfi coast or some such rather than in downtown palm pay.
Uh,
so we speak to see this interesting merging at least for the very well to do the
rich and famous as we the lifestyles of the rich and famous as this.
As this lecture is called.
Uh,
we began to see that in some of the houses,
especially in the later period.
I'd like to the La one of the second to last,
a building that I want to show you is an extremely important one.
The last one we'll just look at for a minute or so,
but this,
this one is an extremely important building.
It is the Ville of the mysteries in Pompei.
It is indeed a villa a.
So it's a nice segue from the Laureus Teper Tina's house.
Uh,
what started to happen in palm pay,
even though there was quite a bit of space initially,
as time went on,
things became more crowded and the really well to do began to move outside the
city to the,
to the suburbs,
so to speak,
right outside the city.
Interestingly enough,
right along those same streets that formed the cemeteries of the city.
So we see this villas in the cemeteries intermixing in a very natural way.
Uh,
but this very important villa was part of that development.
And I want to say it went through a couple of phases and I want to show you the
two phases here.
Uh,
the phase only phase two is on your monument lists.
I won't hold you responsible for phase one,
but I think it's important for us to look at it together because what we see
here is something very interesting.
Uh,
we looking at the top,
we see the entrance into the villa.
We see the peristyle there,
the atrium there,
and the to bleed them there.
Now what do you think about that?
I mean,
it's very strange.
We've never seen a house,
that house or villa that departed from the scheme that we talked about before
from this movement,
from the entrance way,
the foul ks into the peristyle first,
then into the atrium,
then into the,
to bleed them.
It's a different progression.
Uh,
we,
we might,
might think to ourselves,
well this must be the,
the whim of this particular patron,
but Bertrubias tells us otherwise.
But Truvia is,
tells us about villa design and he tells us the major distinction between Roman
villas and Roman houses in terms of their plan is that in Roman villas you enter
into the peristyle first.
So it shows again the growing interest in Paris styles,
uh,
and yet this Paris style very,
very early indeed because it belongs to the first phase,
which is even before the or or you know,
even before the early second century AED,
which is when the second century BC,
which is when the second phase is dated.
We can also see here a great podium and I'll say a bit more about the podium.
As we look at phase two.
This is phase two of the house.
And this is the one that you have at the villa.
This is the one that you have on your monument list.
The main spaces are,
are labeled here.
You can see the entrance way,
the foul case,
the peristyle first,
a very large pallet Paris style,
the Atrium of the house here,
that to bleed them over here.
So this different order described by Vitruvian [inaudible].
We can see also that it rests on a tall podium.
I'll show you what it looks like in a moment.
It is a podium that looks exactly like the Podio we saw for the great
sanctuaries at Tivoli and Palestrina.
We see that underneath that podium just as it,
those are Jupiter anx or terror Cina just as a terror Cina we see there's a crip
to porticas or underground passageway underneath that podium.
It is barrel vaulted and the,
the,
um,
concrete is faced with opus and carrot and work just as we saw it in the
sanctuaries.
Why have this kind of podium here,
uh,
to give the villa and even grander appearance to put it up high on top of a
podium and also to help to,
uh,
to muffle the sounds from the street.
Remember is a major street,
uh,
a thoroughfare that leads it's just left the city and has become an inter city
road,
uh,
to muffle the sounds at one would hear from that by raising the villa in a sense
away from them.
The most important point though that I can make about this villa and something
that speaks to the future is the fact that we are beginning to see.
We've talked about how enclosed and plain and severe the earlier exteriors of
Roman houses were even up through the hell of a nice dome is except perhaps for
the addition of a pilaster or a column here and there.
Here we see something entirely new happening.
We see that the architect has designed these elements,
that project out of the,
uh,
the,
the rectangle of the villa plan,
uh,
and are curved.
And you can see one over here and most importantly one over here.
It's like a giant bay window,
uh,
with,
um,
with w with views,
uh,
that can be seen through that bay window.
So this projecting out into the viewers space and so on and also into the space
of those who live inside this building offering wonderful panoramas and vistas
of the sea beyond the sea was closer to Pompei pay at that point than it
actually is today.
Beautiful views out onto the sea.
Uh,
and they,
they in a sense,
the exterior of the structure breaking out of it's out of it's rectangular
bonds,
uh,
to do something entirely different from what has come before.
This is a restored view of what that structure would have looked like in its
second phase.
And I think you can see that very well here resting on this tall podium arcades
just as at the sanctuaries.
These are blind arcades just as we saw their concrete opus and cared and facing.
But look at the difference that this having this bay window made.
They've opened up the wall.
The windows are very large,
no more slit windows,
big panoramic windows projecting elements.
Also with very large windows is hardly any wall there whatsoever.
The rest is the same.
The comp Blue Beam,
the parasol all look like they did in the Hella Nice Domus.
But this is a big change and one that,
uh,
looks forward again to the future.
This is a view of it as it looks today,
the villa,
the mysteries,
you can see the great podium over here with its blind arcades as well as part of
the house.
And Look at how open that house is.
Now,
part of this is villas.
You know,
there's more of a desire when you build the villa to open it up more so than a
house in town.
But it's also an important development for architecture as a whole.
This is a view of the peristyle court.
It's little different than any other peristyle court we've seen.
Cause you can see they have embedded the columns into the wall of the,
uh,
the wall.
There's a wall around it.
The columns are embedded into that,
which is a different motif.
And I thought she'd be amused to see that.
Um,
the,
the Ville of the mysteries is one of those.
And there are several places in Italy,
many places in Italy where people go in particular to take photos of after their
wedding to take photos of themselves,
photo op places.
And the villa Mr of the mysteries is one of them.
So you don't be at all surprised if you are there,
especially on a weekend if you see a wedding party taking photos and this was
one of the more discreet photos,
you can just imagine the kinds of poses that people take in,
in places like this.
I could've shown you all kinds of very music,
very loving photos of the bride and groom.
But here you just get a sense of awe and the photographer.
And there were several photographers the day I took this,
uh,
getting wonderful,
um,
uh,
images of this bride and groom after the happy event.
I just want to close just very briefly with the,
um,
with this last house or this Mosaic Fountain from this last house.
It's the so called House of the large fountain,
so called because of this extraordinary fountain that was found there.
And still exist dates to between the earthquake and the eruption of Vesuvius 62
to 79 a d it's very well preserved.
You see it here on the right hand side of the screen.
It shows you that mosaics could be applied to any kind of surface by these very
talented artists.
Uh,
this,
this case applied to a curved surface.
As you can see very well here.
Once again,
using multicolored test Iri as we saw in the Alexander mosaic.
And you can only imagine how lovely it was when there was actually a water
display and so on.
In fact,
so lovely that it was imitated almost exactly for the Getty villa and Malibu,
which I saw you on the left hand side of the screen.
Uh,
many of you have probably been there.
The Getty villa,
it looks like Disneyland.
I know,
but it probably gives you a better sense of what a Roman villa looked like in
antiquity.
Then anything else even that you can see in Rome because it's in such pristine
shape.
Uh,
and it really gives you,
it is,
it is based for any of you who don't know.
It is actually based on an on an on a villa from Herculaneum that was excavated.
We know it.
It's based very closely on it.
The so called bill of the Papiri at Herculaneum,
uh,
and then it picks and chooses,
you know,
it looks at other things as well,
incorporates them as it incorporated this fountain.
But it probably gives you,
it's in better condition.
Uh,
you can see that the water display is actually working unlike the one in Palm
Bay.
So it gives you a very good sense of what this thing would have looked like in
antiquity.
And just as a look forward,
uh,
one of the paper topics for this course actually is to,
as to talk about the bill of the Papiri and the context in part and being helped
by,
uh,
the REC reconstruction at the Getty Museum on Thursday.
We will move on to Herculaneum.
We will talk about the lives of the people there,
some of the houses that were built there between the eruption of a,
between the earthquake and Vesuvius.
And we will also begin our conversation about first style and second style Roman
wall painting.
Uh,
we'll have a few lectures on painting because it's so important as the interior
decoration of these homes.
And because as we'll see,
it depicts architecture.
And you can get a sense of that here in ways that are very intriguing.
And the tell us even more about buildings than we already know.
Thanks everybody.
Or good afternoon.
Good morning..